foreign
I grew up with that cold war idea of the
West as a thing that was sort of moral
and great and worth standing up for
against the sort of slave Empire of
Communism and then I suddenly realized
that like 20 30 years no one had been
taught that and the current generation
don't know that story in fact they only
know the other story which is the one
that says you know the West is is
uniquely evil and awful we're up we're
under threat from without because there
are very real people Chinese and the
Russians who are coming together now
very explicitly and saying we want a
different world order what you get in
Magna Carta is the idea of the rule of
law we talked about individualism the
thing about the rule of law is it says
every individual even the king is under
the same law and we can go to court and
we can thrash it out but we'll follow
the rules and we'll see who comes out on
top the other threat is is inside and
that is the fact that we have started to
not teach first of all to not teach
about Magna Carta or the west or what it
is and in fact to teach the opposite to
teach that it is awful so foundations of
of the western system are just being
knocked down casually by people who
don't understand because they can be
taught what they mean and how everything
that they value
everything that you know makes their
lives what they are rest on these things
and you know there's a reckoning that
can come with that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a terrific guest today is a
senior fellow at the new culture forum
and the presenter and director of a
brilliant series and I'm not just saying
because I was in it it is actually very
very good here on YouTube called the
West Mark said well welcome to
trigonometry thanks so much for having
me oh it's so great to have you I I
already told you the story but our
audience should know a lot of people so
you recorded some interviews with a lot
of people and I was one of them uh and I
never had a chance to watch it because
I've got a lot of stuff that I'm working
on whatever but so many people kept
saying to me oh that series you were in
is so good called the West so I
eventually watched it and it is actually
brilliant before we talk about it though
do tell us who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that brings you here
talking to us so I I work with a number
of think tanks I'm a senior fellow at
the new culture Forum which which made
the series I'm also the head of research
at Jackson society which stands up for
the free Society at home and abroad but
actually I had a long Gap in between I
used to work for think tanks about 15
years ago and then I thought well the
world's doing okay I think these
problems are going to be fine and I went
off to have a career in business
journalism and I thought that'd be fine
and I looked up and I thought oh the the
world is actually is gone mad since the
end of the Cold War things haven't gone
well Russia hasn't democratized China
certainly isn't coming to the family of
Nations and things at home are getting
increasingly unfree and intolerant and
and so it brought me back because I
thought we needed to start talking about
these questions again or I needed to to
re-engage with with the debate and in
particular the idea of of the West which
is really the idea of this series
because you know I'm an 80s kid I I grew
up with that cold war idea of of the
West as a thing that was sort of moral
and great and worth standing up for
against the sort of slave Empire of
Communism and then I suddenly realized
that like 20 30 years no one had been
taught that and the current generation
don't know that story in fact they only
know the other story which is the one
that says you know the West is is
uniquely evil and awful so I thought I
wanted to use new technology for a new
generation and tell that story again
that no one had heard for a long time
and you do it beautifully and one of the
things I really enjoyed about and
actually our producer Anton was saying
it to you as you were sitting down how
informative it is I'm I'd like to think
I'm one of the West's big fans over a
whole book about it but I actually
learned so much uh one of the things
that you you talk about that I found
fascinating is that the idea of
democracy or the idea that Authority
should be answerable to the people below
actually comes from barbarians that was
really interesting tell us about that
well yeah the the older traditional idea
of of the West often is told in a
narrative that goes back to ancient
Greece and Rome as if there was a sort
of unbroken tradition and it's very true
that the West draws on some ideas from
ancient Greece and from Rome it was a
big influence but there are problems
historically with that narrative there's
really there's a big break that happens
and the West I think really begins with
the fall of Rome it's what happens after
the Empire goes and then you get the
barbarians the Germanic tribes that come
in and they're really they're very poor
they're primitive but they have this
enormous focus on the individual and
other sort of individual pride and as a
result a sort of culture of not quite
democracy but of Freedom that of free
men who sort of vote together as who
should be their leader and that culture
I think was enormously important in
informing the west and giving it shape I
mean not just on its own I think also
it's the interaction of that with with
Christianity which is really the form in
which the traditions of Rome came into
that into that part of Europe because
Christianity and the church survived the
fall of Rome but I think that's a much
more honest place to start the
conversation about the west and also it
gets away from this sort of grand idea
of the West as something that sort of
Roman and Imperial and gets back to the
real truth the the adventure of the West
is this poor primitive divided corner of
Europe that is nothing like as Rich
Nothing Like Us civilized in in
traditional terms as other parts of the
world like like China and the Islamic
world but that nonetheless has this
thing in it this spark out of which are
going to come things that have never
been seen before in human history things
like experimental science like
industrial capitalism like parliamentary
democracy there was something there
something there that's about the
individual and that that is partly I
think an inheritance out of those
Germanic trials it's so interesting
because I've never really thought about
it like that but actually the story of
the West and the way that you describe
it is a story of depending how you want
to look at it either coming from very
humble beginnings or a tremendous
recovery from a gigantic setback which
is the collapse of Rome and then you
know I remember seeing
um various exhibitions here in the UK
about what happened after the Romans
left Britain and the tribes that came
after who hadn't directly been in
contact with the Roman civilization they
the gap between them and the Romans
technologically were so vast that they
thought that the buildings that the
Romans are directed here which were
nothing as impressive as the ones they
built actually in Rome
were the work of gods because they
couldn't imagine engineering at that
level and to come from that to being the
most successful civilization in the
history of the world is quite remarkable
isn't it it's quite remarkable and I
think the West you know it's the Triumph
of the smallest the Triumph of
giving power to individuals it didn't
really happen because of like a grand
Theory it happened because when Rome
fell and and then Europe was divided no
one could exert power from above to tell
people what to do plus you had this this
culture from below that was quite
individualistic anyway so then people
were free to to play around with ideas
there wasn't enough people who could who
could quash it traditional civilizations
which in many ways the West isn't are
much more about stability about power
from the top about great Empires and the
problem with that is you can get to
quite a high level of sophistication but
it's primary virtue is stability and
stasis and the people at the top keeping
power and they say no to the dangerous
crazy ideas that might take them forward
and so that's why you don't get
industrialization happening elsewhere
where you don't get all the crazy
inventions you know Columbus going to
the new world well so the Chinese had
great treasure Voyage is huge much more
sophisticated fleets that went out into
the world but they weren't that
interested because they thought they
were more important and it was all
controlled from the Imperial Court so in
the Imperial Court said well we don't
want to do that anymore and the ships
burn the ships whatever no one goes in
Europe you have an independent crazy guy
Columbus who's like I think that we can
get you know to to Asia by going over
the ocean and he was he was wrong that
you could do that because he thought the
world was much smaller than it actually
was and you know smart people could have
told him that but he had a crazy idea
and he he went around to different
monarchs in Europe and he said give me
some money I'll go I'll go and do this
some said no but there was always
someone else you could go to and in fact
I discovered which I didn't know that if
if the Spanish hadn't said yes Henry the
the seventh I think it was in in England
had said yes he said yes to Columbus's
brother but by the time he got back
they'd already gone with Spanish money
so it's an interesting counterfactual
you know that the English might have
been the financiers of that Voyage but
the point was it couldn't be stopped
there's something Unstoppable in the
west because it's so divided and broken
and competitive there's always another
Power Center that you can go to that
means wild ideas sort of bubble up it's
a really good point because you wouldn't
get that in China like you said before
there's so many aspects of your
documentary that I found fascinating in
particular when you talk about Empire
and the slave trade because it seems to
me we have an absolutely blinkered
approach to talking about these subjects
which understandably can be seen as
quite contentious absolutely you know I
think this is this is very important
because it it's become a huge debate of
the moment as to you know how should we
feel about the British Empire and that's
by no means is a particularly
pro-imperial
um series that's I tend to think that
Empire is the sort of traditional
solution of civilization you build a
giant Empire the interesting thing about
the European ones for all their their
faults and obviously Terrible Things uh
suddenly happened but there were lots of
them so even there there was competition
going on but there was also you know all
of these different very unusual European
values Western values bubbling under the
surface about the individual about you
know that what you could and couldn't do
to other peoples and how you might want
to to bring them on board I I talk about
the example of Columbus again who you
know a very complicated figure not not
always a great guy
um brought back some slaves native
slaves to to Spain and the monarchs said
well can we actually actually have these
slaves is that is that right and they
spent several years thinking about and
they said well no
these are potential Christians these are
people we could convert and that means
that they have to be treated with
respect they actually can't be enslaved
and that was you know quite a bold way
of thinking about the native uh
populations you know because the sheer
power dynamically you could obviously
you could enslave them but actually
maybe there were reasons you couldn't
though the tragedy apparently of what
happened in the new world was was to do
with you know the epidemics that were no
one could predict or control which just
wiped out millions and millions of
people with diseases they weren't used
to being exposed to absolutely in
particular in South America when the
Spanish came over there's a his joke in
in Venezuela that they conquistadors
gave the native population the flu and
then the flu gave the native population
gonorrhea yeah so it was a lovely little
Exchange
but I was going to say do you guys watch
the flu no you mean the natives gave no
no no no no the Spanish gave this gave
the native population the flu the flu ER
the flu the native population gave us
what I was correct you said the flu gave
them gonorrhea all right okay that is a
really interesting mix that is a version
of History I have never heard but but do
you sometimes get frustrated at how we
discuss these topics because in in a way
well in many ways it's completely it's
ridiculous it's being discussed from a
point of view that knows the answer I
think that's the problem and knows the
answer basically is that the West is
awful and the empires were terrible and
that you know slavery was a was a of the
West the transatlantic slave trade which
obviously was a horrific thing was the
worst thing ever in history and there
was nothing else like it and that you
know Western sin is the thing we must
focus on and that that has no Nuance it
has no historical context and it really
just
it exists to kind of gnaw at Western
Confidence from within which really
matters it matters today because that's
the spirit you need to resist real
Alternatives in the world real
Alternatives from China from from Russia
which are which are places which
you know they are now the first to stand
up make Grand speeches about how the
West is is evil and you know talk about
anti-colonialism and talk about all the
Terrible Things the West did while they
are literally putting people in camps
while they are literally aggressively
invading other countries but they use
this anti-western language to to sort of
make up as if we are the villains while
they're doing truly Dreadful things and
we need that confidence to stand up
against that and we can't have that
if we if we have this idea this false
idea of history in which we are always
the villains without even checking the
facts there's a great book by Nigel Big
R uh and I interview him for the series
as well and you know I talked to Nigel
about it and that book he says in the
book and he said to me you know the
reason he writes it is not just to tell
the truth about Empire and colonialism
to offer a more nuanced moral account
but because that matters because
otherwise we don't have the confidence
today to preserve liberal Democratic
civilization against the forces which
are which are ranged against it and it's
a great point because if you spoke to
someone about the transatlantic slave
trade they would be able to tell you
certain things about it and they would
be able to explain why it happened but
if you ask someone about the
trans-saharan slave trade they wouldn't
have a clue I mean most people wouldn't
unless they read my book or heard your
wonderful interview about it which is in
the series I think which is which is
very good we have this comment station
about whether slavery should be taught
in schools and so on and my answer to
that is yes the problem is we don't
teach about slavery in schools what we
teach about is the transatlantic slave
trade and this way of looking at the
world is is quite silly to me it's sort
of like evaluating whether a sprinter is
fast or slow without comparing them to
anybody else you can't do it you have to
understand what was happening everywhere
else at the same time and I talk about
my own family history of being slaves in
Russia I talk about what was happening
in my country what was happening in
Africa when the evil Western
colonialists arrived and by the way the
transatlantic's later it was absolutely
Evil by the standards of the modern day
but it wasn't as bad as the the
trans-saharan slave trade which was
conducted mainly by Muslim and Arab
traders
um didn't last as long didn't take as
many lives didn't have such a high death
rate and slavery was continued
continually practiced around the world
my much later and only ended by the way
thanks to the Western Colonial powers
putting a lot of effort and a lot of
money into it does that excuse the
transatlantic slave trade of course not
but it gives you the context to
understand that the Western powers are
and remain some of the most Progressive
tolerant societies that have ever been
created and are crimes which are many
there's no doubt there are many should
be seen in the context of that in the
context of the fact that other great
civilizations and Empires around the
world were doing the exact same things
and worse at the same time and we ended
it we stopped it not only did we end it
within our own Empires and our own
borders but we also then spent over a
century spending vast amounts of money
and power and treasure out in the world
trying to enforce this on other people
and trying to stop slavery wherever we
could
Britain was among the first states in
the history of the world
to abolish the slave trade and then to
abolish slavery and it then led the
world in suppressing both of those as I
said from Brazil across Africa to
Malaysia that was extraordinary no other
state had done that before
no other states had done that before
certainly not in Africa certainly not in
Asia nor in among the Indians peoples of
North America that was extraordinary and
and we carried on doing that
for until the end of the empire in the
1960s and in 1820s and 30s the slavery
trade Department in the British foreign
office was the largest unit
um and in the 1830s or the 40s there
about 13 of the total Manpower of their
own Navy was devoted to um
um into in to stopping
uh slave ships leaving West Africa for
the Americas
uh just stopping that quite apart from
stopping slavery elsewhere
and that is an extraordinary Legacy an
extraordinary moment in human history
where slavery goes from being
part of the background something that's
awful maybe but something that is kind
of understood that it happens sometimes
to being something that's morally
unacceptable and morally unacceptable
because of a deep understanding of what
the principles of western western
civilization are and that to live up to
those more fully we're going to have
just just wipe this thing out which
brings us neatly onto Christianity
because that's really what you're
talking about but before we go there uh
I went to the slavery Museum in
Liverpool and in many ways it's very
good but nowhere in it and I went
through the whole thing because it's an
interesting subject historically
speaking to look at does it say who was
it that sold the slaves nor does it
really talk about how the slave trade
was ended around the world by the way
who whose idea was that it should not
happen
um can't trust scousers but that's
certainly true we have a Scouts of
running the show
um but uh Christianity Mark
um
what is the role that Christianity plays
in the development of our civilization
because there are some people that might
argue and David Starkey who's the former
guest on our show who might argue
actually it's it's the religion that
brings down the Roman Empire it's it's
the sort of wokeness of antiquity uh
that sort of uh takes a powerful and
confident civilization and makes it Meek
and feeble and so on and yet here we are
uh so what is the story of Christianity
in the context of our civilization well
Christianity is a morally revolutionary
way of thinking about the world it is
itself against
dominance and and power from the top and
in many ways against Empire arguably uh
and it was a revolution inside the Roman
system of course the Roman system being
Imperial was in many ways very cruel
very terrible to women in particular it
was often the women who understood first
of all you know the attraction of
Christianity
and it spoke powerfully after the Roman
period to these Germanic tribes this was
a whole new kind of heroism and they
were very attracted to I think in part I
think because it was a heroism that was
Democratic it wasn't just a few people
at the top who could who could be heroes
you know the sort of the true
Aristocrats but anyone and that everyone
mattered and that that became a very
very powerful force in in Western
history and you know more recently I
suppose there has been a tendency to see
uh the sort of key liberal Democratic
ideas that's coming later coming very
much from the the enlightenment say but
scholarship I think has moved on since
that time when you see books more
popular books like Tom Holland's book
Dominion uh more scholarly books like
Larry sedentop's book inventing the
individual which go back much further in
time and say you really have to look to
the medieval period to the period where
where Christianity is this sort of
dominant intellectual system inside
Europe inside the west and that that is
what shapes a lot of these ideas about
human rights individual rights and
indeed democracy as well and that that
comes through into the present day
we're so Christian in a way that we
don't culturally that we don't really
recognize it anymore it's like a fish
being in water and not knowing what
water is and that doesn't mean that
everyone needs to be Christian or you
need some kind of you know
um imposed Christianity but but
culturally the the ideas that we take
for granted are are in many ways
Christian as you say the the the fight
against the slave trade was was
profoundly driven uh by by Christian
sentiment and I think that
that Christian ability to go somewhere
revolutionary and to say well we know
this is the established system this is
like you know the economy is built on it
in certain ways and it's making people
rich and this is just how things have
been done but say well actually no
no and an ordinary person like William
Wilberforce or someone who drinks their
their tea with sugar in it can turn
around and say I can't be part of this
and I won't have any sugar from enslaved
uh plantations or I'll stand up against
this you know that vast popular movement
that anti-slavery was was imbued with
that that spirit and that that's very
Christian
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country would
judge Men's Health by his ability to
wrestle there in London I have since
found out this has very different
meaning we've all had a night that's got
out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my unsuspect well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle America which we all know is
grotosely weak compared to Great Russian
Bear if you're looking for a simpler and
cost effective supplement routine ag1 is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try edgy1 and get five free edu1
travel packs and a free one-year supply
of vitamin D with your first purchase go
to drink ag1.com trigonometry that's
drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
Mark I'm feeling a historical gap for me
how do we go from the the collapse of
the Roman Empire which by this point is
already Christian basically yeah yeah uh
to the Barbarian sort of that period and
then the emergence of medieval kingdoms
which are all pretty much universally
Christian in Europe how does that happen
how do The Barbarians become
christianized over time well as I say
the the church is really the one bit of
of the Roman system that survives
because it's not really you know part of
of the Empire but it's there within it
and and it has a sort of network across
Europe of Bishops it has uh monasteries
see you have this this system forming
that can survive the the collapse and as
the Empire goes away the church is there
providing a network of of local power
and of knowledge and literacy even often
and so that provides something of an
intellectual culture that can then
crystallize around the these various
humanic tribes and they recognize
something in it they recognize the
fascination of the ideas they quite like
this sort of individualistic aspect they
find in it and they turn it into
something perhaps rather more warlike
that appeals to them as well there's a
you know different ways you can receive
Christianity they rather liked it as
something they could wave as a Battle
Flag as they went in which been true in
the Roman times too that's why um you
know
um Constantine uh took it up as as a
symbol of the Cross to go into battle
under uh but but so the Germans took
that or The Barbarians we should say
took that idea and then it became though
a new kind of culture that formed
particularly in the northern monasteries
in Britain uh and then from there
a long way from the old Imperial centers
in Rome you get this new culture forming
particularly in the monasteries and then
you get a new movement back onto the
continent so you get this this new
imperial system trying to start up under
under the Carol engines
and they they call a monk from Britain
to go there and and to take this new
sort of mixture of the old classical
culture and the sort of new thinking
that's starting to emerge and to teach
them that becomes a new way of teaching
Europe and then that Imperium that
attempt to recreate the Roman Empire
goes away but these ideas start to
spread and and Europe starts to reform
not as one Empire but as a series of
competing Nations but they they share
this uh a Common Language of Latin and
then also the local languages as well
and so you get a mixture of the ability
to have a sort of shared intellectual
culture but also local National cultures
as well and that's again so important in
the west this ability to have different
different nations different cultures
different centers it's competing power
centers and there's always a
restlessness and that restlessness could
be very bloody lots and lots of Wars but
at the same time that allows new
technologies to develop the war fact
technologies that develop in the west
particularly the use of gunpowder
gunpowder comes from China doesn't
really develop in the same way there as
it does in Europe and it's because
Europe is fighting amongst itself that
there has to be a kind of arms race
there with the new technology but also
because
their developing systems within these
nations to raise money for the wars and
that actually is parliaments parliaments
are a very good way to legitimately
raise more money from the nation in
order to go and fight the wars and
therefore to develop better gunpowder
technology or longbows or crossbows to
fight with so
people sometimes want to separate out
the best bits of the west from the other
bits and say oh well you know democracy
and it's Peaceable but oh yeah we used
to fight Wars it's it's the competitive
war-like things that were going on
inside the West which are tied to its
Christianity that are tied to its
parliaments
the West is a complex and dangerous
thing we shouldn't imagine it's it's
perfect or it's wonderful it was just
this extraordinary fusion and out of it
you get these things that just didn't
happen elsewhere and you talk about
things that don't happen elsewhere but
you touch on the Magna Carta and I found
that fascinating because I can't really
remember in my education being taught
about the Magna Carta or why it was so
important to our nation so let's explore
that yeah yeah but you know this sort of
stuff used to be taught all the time
everywhere there used to be jokes about
that's why there's the joking you know
the old the old Hancock
[Music]
because you know everyone would know
what what it was and why that wasn't
wasn't correct we stop we've stopped
teaching this history what you get in
Magna Carta and this is really something
that I I think is Central we perhaps
haven't talked enough about yet is the
idea of the rule of law we talked about
individualism
the thing about the rule of law is it
says every individual even the king is
under the same law and we can go to
court and we can thrash it out but we'll
follow the rules and we'll see who comes
out on top it's not but because you're
rich and powerful and the King that you
can just do what you like everyone gets
a fair shot in corner I mean you know
maybe someone's got a better lawyer but
in theory and Magna Carta is the point
one of the key points where we say that
it's fairly early days in the
development of that idea to be fair
right it's the Barons taking some of the
power away from the King it's not like
the ordinary you know the idea that the
ordinary person is entitled to the same
Justice as a king in that day would have
been ridiculous yeah but you know it's
there it's there in principle it's it's
the Barons we're fighting for it and
even though it's just Barons against the
king sort of print slings against a
prince but that there is still it's not
one Emperor over the court over the
great Empire and it's those divisions
that eventually play down and mean that
everyone is ultimately in the same place
and before that too you know the the Old
Law codes of of people like the
Visigoths talking about The Barbarians
again you know which is a name that we
use to mean sort of completely
outrageous and barbaric people would
tear things down they had very very
strong law codes that were about giving
people rights giving giving women rights
um
they could choose who to marry after
they got to a certain ages like 20 or
something like that you know so not not
exactly modern rights but you know more
than you might expect
but that that idea of of law I think is
is Central and you know something that
occurred to me in working on this is we
don't even notice how deep it is
culturally for us like you look around
at every big news story like the Supreme
Court this week very important decisions
going down in America it's a it's a it's
a law story or you go and you know look
at novels or movies say it's a it's John
Grisham things like this
um or you know in Shakespeare it's um uh
it's Merchant of Venice
law
again so so common we don't even notice
it is this really powerful thing and
then you go somewhere else you go to
China
there's no rule of law there are things
that might look like it there are things
that might look like courts but China is
a place where there are what
two to five million people in prison not
a single one of them has had a fair
trial you know it's like 99 of of
prosecutions ending convictions 99 of
appeals are refused this is not is not a
system has anything approaching rule of
law I was talking this week with some
some Western businessmen who spent time
in inside Chinese prisons and you know
it's terrifying to hear those stories
and it's those moments when you suddenly
realize how much we take for granted I
think this is a big problem with the
West right it's like we grow up in it we
used to we think we think oh this is
just how things are you take one step
outside that and you suddenly realize
how different
things can be it doesn't have to be this
way and that's a great point we do take
things for granted and you talk about in
the documentary you use the word threat
several times and you say the West is
under threat well I mean what do you
mean by that Mark I mean look around
we're not under threat are we I mean
France maybe but not here
we're under threat from without and
we're under threat from within we're
under threat from without because there
are very real people Chinese and the
Russians who are who are coming together
now very explicitly and saying we want a
different world order we think our way
even though involves putting people in
camps for their religion or because it
involves us shamelessly invading and
butchering people in another country but
we think our way is better than your way
and if we can we're going to take over
and we're going to impose a different
system a system in which individuals
don't matter in which things are run
from the top in which there is no rule
of law now okay we can feel pretty safe
from that here maybe but you know
they're getting they're getting stronger
they're very powerful we are really
going to care about them if Chinese
invade Taiwan and suddenly we can't get
the the microchips that run everything
in our country you know from from Cars
to watches to to mobile phones this
stuff really will affect us just as your
energy bills last winter your energy
bills this winter are affected by what
Putin's up to in Ukraine even if you
don't care or have those sort of
personal connection that Constantine
does to what's going on there uh so that
is a real threat but the other threat is
is inside and that is the fact that
especially at the top level in the
universities in the schools we have
started to not teach first of all to not
teach about Magna Carta or the west or
what it is and in fact to teach the
opposite to teach that it is awful that
we've done terrible things we need to
apologize for them and that we're not
very special if we are special we're
special in being awful
and if you do that it's like I was
saying about what Nigel bigger has been
working on you if you do that you don't
have the confidence to stand up against
people like Russia and China and things
inside start to go away and even without
that external threat you start to throw
things away because you don't think you
need them you start to tear down
meritocracy you start to say well
equality is all very well this
individualistic approach but you know we
need to do more for people of color or
we need to do more for certain groups so
and actually we won't we won't judge
people by the content of their character
anymore we'll start judging them by the
color of their skin
scientific objectivity oh that's very
nice but maybe we should look at other
systems of knowing and not worry so much
about you know just following objective
reality
we are in a period where
you know the basic building blocks the
foundations of of the western system are
just being knocked down casually by
people who don't understand because they
haven't been taught what they mean and
how everything that they value
everything that you know makes their
lives what they are rest on these things
and you know that there's a reckoning
that can come with that
and do you think that this is how
civilizations collapse and implode is
this what happened to the Roman Empire
is this what happened to other Empires
or is it something different I think the
West is so different that it's hard to
draw comparisons the thing about most
traditional civilizations is that
they're very stable right you have this
authoritative system from above it
doesn't change that much it can become
quite Grand and go on for a long time
but it can break quite fast and and then
they don't really have a way to come
back the west of course has already
fallen in a way it's it's like it's sort
of starts in a sort of post-apocalyptic
setting of Western Europe after the
Empire's gone and that makes it very
resilient it's it's sort of distributed
bottom-up system so and it also means it
continually renews itself so I think the
West does have the potential to survive
and go on much longer than a normal
civilization but
it needs to hold on to itself and if it
doesn't do that you know it can just get
lost and because it's so unusual in
human history it could get replaced by
you know it could go back to the norm we
could get back to a system of top-down
control go back to all the things that
are kind of the default of human history
and we need to hold on to it just
because it's so unusual and that you
know it it has so much more to give we
we aren't there yet right you know the
West keeps changing and moving upward
someone
Walter Russell Mead the historian says
you know we are we're building a space
rocket we're not we're not building a
rest home we're here to you know go to
the stars and keep doing crazy new
things the West is
needs to hold on to its roots but you
know it keeps growing up into the sky as
well trying to live up to these
extraordinary ideals that it has and
Mark one of the great gifts the western
civilization did give to the world is
The Enlightenment and the Scientific
Revolution how does that happen
how does that come about what is the
process that the West takes
to get to that point where suddenly
people decide oh let's let's you know
invent the scientific method and and
think about you know various things that
come with the enlightenment it's an
incredibly hard thing to do this is this
is why it doesn't happen elsewhere and
in the west it takes a very long time as
well West has two things going for it
though apart from you know it's General
it's General sort of individualistic
sort of setting where mad ideas can can
be allowed to sort of bubble through
firstly it's quite an inventive culture
and that was always true there's two
from the Germanic days you get things uh
going on with a lot of automation early
well before the Industrial Revolution
you've got water Mills windmills these
These are taken to a new level of
sophistication in the west so that there
there's an inventiveness going on you've
also got Christianity which we've talked
about before now Christianity is
sometimes seen particularly from sort of
Enlightenment perspective as being
somewhat opposed to Scientific thought
and suddenly there were moments when it
the the center of the church wanted to
stand against certain certain ideas but
uh Christianity in the west at its root
had the idea of a of a of a reasoned
order that that God himself was uh
logical and created an ordered creation
that followed certain rules
and one of the key inventions I talk
about in the series which is very early
on you know in the in the Middle Ages is
the invention of the mechanical clock
and this doesn't happen elsewhere you
get water clocks you get um sand clocks
sand timers things that are about the
flow of time but to create a machine
that that ticks and talks and sees time
as distinct units it's really very
different very very challenging thing to
build and it turns up in the Middle Ages
and it's actually used not just to be in
every town square and to you know help
people coordinate their days and work in
different ways but also to demonstrate
models of the cosmos and these models
are wrong they're sort of Christian
models in which the sun is it the the
Earth is at the center and the Sun and
everything else goes around it but it's
very much a sort of clockwork Universe
built by God With Us at the center of it
and that you know survives for centuries
but it's tied you see this this rational
Christian order to this idea of an
orderly world where you can build things
within it and you can follow the rules
and you can make new things like like
the clock
so that that's there that's all under
the surface it's very hard to get from
that to experimental science it starts
to happen in the universities which is a
place again where different ideas can
come along
what you really need to do is you need
to put the theoretical thinking together
with the the people who are good with
their hands and that that just takes a
very long time for people to get around
to it and to start to do it and it
starts to happen when they start to
notice the gaps in the Clockwork
universe that they've got they start to
say oh
animal there's a star in the sky that
shouldn't be there if we have this this
neat mechanical model it was it was a
supernova and then someone invents uh
the the telescope which comes out of
another very interesting invention which
is eyeglasses but the telescope suddenly
allows you to look at things in the sky
and you see the moon and it doesn't look
like the theory says it is
and so it's people you know we think
about I know Galileo we think about
these people as just having ideas or
doing Theory but they're working with
their hands to build new instruments to
see things
and it's that ability to combine the two
to have an idea of theory and Abstract
theory about the world and then to build
things to help you test it and that's
what starts to develop and in fact that
that feeds into the industrial
revolution as well because
well James Watt does with the with the
steam engine which is the center of that
is to improve it and to make it more
efficient but he does it by by knowing
theoretical people by talking to them
about their new ideas and then you know
hammering and going and smelting and
working with iron to see if he can make
a new thing that works and trying and
trying again so that sort of trial and
error with the hands put together with
this sort of theoretical abstract
thinking about the world and that then
those two together
suddenly you have this ability to to not
just have one invention but sort of have
a way of inventing and inventing and
getting to know this ordered World in a
whole new way and it just opens doors
that you know we're still we're still
walking through and it's the ability to
tolerate heretical thought as well
although that wasn't always the case and
of course there were great thinkers who
unfortunately paid with their lives for
their for their thinking their thoughts
and their work but we were able to
tolerate that in the west weren't we we
were able to tolerate that within
universities because they were kind of
independent institutions that goes back
to the idea of law you know they could
special law that allow them to be these
independent corporations but also
because they were sort of independent
princes so again it's a bit like
Columbus you go and find another Patron
go for another Power Center that'll
protect you for their own personal
reasons from the papacy so yeah you know
maybe the pope doesn't want you to say
that
um we're not at the center of the
universe but you know there's probably a
prince up the road who will look after
you and have you at his court
particularly if you're going to help him
come up with cool new inventions that
maybe help him defeat his neighbors or
something and do you think that is the
main difference between the west and the
Islamic world because there's any
because as a lot of people will be able
to tell you at one point the Islamic
world was streets ahead of us when it
came to science and maths Etc absolutely
yeah and you know I talk about in the in
the documentary how there's a lot of
sort of westernized names that we have
for the people who really influenced us
in important ways and provided things
into the West that we'd we'd lost
al-hazam is very important for for
lenses so his tracts are picked up by by
Roger Bacon in England and that leads in
some ways to spectacles the theory is
all wrong that's the interesting part
about that is they just they have these
theoretical ideas but they're not
developing them practically so they're
not they're not testing them in some
ways it gets a bit Frozen there there's
a point yeah where they they could have
gone down that road but this
is what as I say it's kind of the
default of human history you have these
flowerings or these moments where
knowledge could break through but
ultimately you're within
civilized system in the sense of
something that sort of controlled by
great princes from the top down it's
very centralized it doesn't have
somewhere you can go and hide from that
and think the crazy thoughts and it gets
it gets shut down and there's a lot of
documentary makers who say that when
they make a documentary I'm a huge fan
of documentaries I love them that it's a
real journey it's almost a journey of a
discovery when you make a documentary so
what did you actually learn as you were
doing this
yeah it was it was a huge journey and
you know the funny thing with with
constantin's interviews we did that what
sort of you know in in the summer or
something and that was like six months
or so before we were returning to it and
trying to work out which bits to use you
do have a sort of time to really sort of
think things through I think um one
thing I've mentioned already the idea of
Law and how important that was to the
West uh that's something that really
struck me as I was making it
um
but I think too it's
it made me more optimistic about the
West because a lot of a lot of people
can be like oh we're all doomed or if
they think about the West they think oh
well you know even if I like it it's
it's in Decline but when you study it's
it's story and you realize how often
it's been you know in in a terrible
state or in the bottom of a hole and
it's it's come back and you see this
this sort of structure that it has where
it had it it can sort of reinvent itself
from below because it's so distributed
um you know this idea of the West as in
Twilight is in Decline it's like the
place of sunset but it's I really don't
think so it's always it's always the sun
coming over the horizon there's always
another Dawn in the west and so that
that made me much more optimistic but in
a way
I think that's that's so important
because it's people thinking oh the West
is over isn't it even if you think it's
fine and it had an interesting run its
day is done really now isn't it once you
start thinking that
you're looking around for someone to
surrender to because you're wondering
well who's going to be next maybe it's
China maybe it's Russia maybe it's the
Soviet Union you know
um you need to have some confidence that
there's still exciting things for us to
do otherwise you know why would you
bother to keep our institutions our
Traditions alive well we are locked now
culturally in I mean I'm so glad you
came onto that because this is you've
talked about the past but the Futures
are arguably more important although
depending on the past of course
um we're locked in this cultural
standoff now between a bunch of
different groups but one of the things
that's going on is you have this group
of people who've essentially uh either
given up on the west or people who think
the West is uniquely evil for the
reasons that you elaborated on and on
the other hand you have people who are
so fed up of what those people are doing
to the West that they've also given up
on the west and now they are you know
some of them you see this online
certainly sort of celebrating Vladimir
Putin as this great savior
you know and that's because I think they
are so fed up with a lot of the cultural
changes they see in the west and I
suppose uh one of the things I see out
of this conversation that I wanted to
ask you is if it is a an essential
quality of our civilization that we keep
disrupting ourselves
what does that mean for our future
because a lot of people would argue I
mean our show is based on essentially
going like what the hell is going on and
there's a lot of disruption very fast
paced change a lot of lots of normal
people are suddenly finding themselves
in a position where like the beliefs
they had two years ago are now really
like outrageous and can't be said in
public and and the pace of change seems
to be getting faster and faster so where
does that leave us going forward
we have to find a way to to adjust to
that change and hold on to something and
that that is the riddle of the West I
talk about it a bit in in the last
episode of the series you know we have
a tradition of of disrupting of doing
new things and we we need that because
you just put us under glass and I'll say
well we've got to sort of hold on to
this tradition as like a you know as a
static thing it won't it won't work
um and that it's really difficult but I
think what we used to have when we would
talk about the west and say well no
these are the things that matter you
know about treating individuals equally
about about democracy
the institutional framework that we've
built up free speech all these things
those are the things we've built to sort
of hold and channel the the Western
energy into Healthy Directions and into
a way that everyone can live their lives
in ways that are you know fruitful and
we can continue to grow the economy and
do more exciting things discover new
things
and so those are the things we have to
preserve and people people now just
carelessly tearing things down because
they don't understand you know how much
they matter but if we don't have that
well you know there are two dangers one
danger is the danger of you know
slipping back into a sort of Russia
China type you know system which is
which is terrifying in its own way the
other thing is that that that Western
Spirit which is I think quite dangerous
if it's not contained within these
institutions
that's
it goes back in a way to the worst of
the barbarians right because those
Germanic tribes were brutal and
uncivilized in many ways and
Christianity and all the other things of
the West as spent centuries turning that
energy into something more fruitful but
you know the social justice Warriors or
the people on the you know the right who
think you know Bronze Age mindset is the
way to go both of those are harking back
to a pre-western idea which is thrilling
but very very dangerous and they're loot
because they don't have the the
tradition of of the West what that
turned that heroic impulse into at the
center of the West you know there is
this heroic impulse your life matters
you are on an adventure and you are the
hero at the center of it
but you need to Center that within the
institutions that allow that to not just
be destructive and tear everyone down
and make everything worse for everyone
else and and the way to do that is is
all the institutions that we've spent
centuries working out and what impact
has the fact that we've become and I'm
saying this is an agnostic causes an
agnostic what has the impact of the
decline in Christianity had on our
civilization
well of course it's a decline in church
attendance more than it is in some ways
a decline in Christian values I think
and I I think one of the problems at the
moment is people don't quite know how to
teach that but I think you can't really
be culturally literate in the west if
you don't know something about
Christianity which doesn't mean teaching
people to follow it as a faith but they
surely need to know something about it
because you can't really understand not
just our art you can't really understand
you know the Sistine Chapel or you know
Michelangelo's David or lots of things
like that but but also a lot of a lot of
intellectual thought as well which you
know is based around uh very Christian
principles so there needs to be I think
some grounding in that and and that is
is very important to people I mean you
know I'm a Christian myself I think you
know if people go to church they'll find
that there's something very important
and Powerful there but uh it's not to
say that everyone in the west uh needs
to be Christian but what's emerged from
that Christian background because
Christianity in the West
place so much emphasis on choice on
people choosing who they marry on people
choosing the faith for themselves that
it's created a space in which
you can choose what religion you follow
for yourself and that's a very Western
sort of culturally Christian ideal so as
long as we have that we have the basis
of a of a society in which people can
choose to be Christian then that's a
good thing perhaps one of the worries in
today's culture is that is that
Christians themselves are maybe moving
into a sort of a negative world where
they're they're treated as somehow
culturally hostile and alien and people
who need to be sort of pushed out of the
Public Square
um so that that concerns me more than
the idea that just not so many people
are going to church and I really like
the fact that you are optimistic because
it's so refreshing because you know on
this show as well we talk to you know
all don't different types of people with
different viewpoints and it can be very
very easy to slip into a negative
mindset it can be that it's very
tempting and there's a lot of people who
make a lot of money on it particularly
on this platform so let's look at
grounds for optimism why are you
optimistic
I'm optimistic because in the end the
energy of individual people to come up
with crazy ideas they're going to sort
things out is the most powerful force in
the world you know look at um the Wright
brothers coming up with the play
just before they did powered flight
there had been a big project to do it
you know our sort of government support
loads didn't work and there's a big big
editorial in the New York Times I mean
maybe it's going to take a thousand
years for us to come up with powered
flight that's that's the way of things
if you just rely on that
couple of bicycle mechanics playing
around again what I was talking about
before tinkering and using Theory both
together
and suddenly they do this thing which
transforms Human Experience and suddenly
allows us to do a thing that we've
dreamed of throughout human history
never been able to do and that's at you
know an unparalleled thing to unlock but
it's too dangerous
for places like Russia it's too
dangerous for places like China because
it brings down those those systems and
then they know that they can't stand it
that's why you got things like Tiananmen
Square where they have to crush the
revolt and you know sort of mash the
protesters who are pro-democracy into
you know into into blood and Pulp with
tanks
but once you stop having that then you
can't discover these things they've got
as far as they have recently because
they've taken up the ideas that we've
invented and but we used to think that
that this was too optimistic we used to
think oh well China is going to become
like us because it's going to become
rich and Industrial and that'll be fine
it doesn't work like that you can become
rich and stay within you know a very
totalitarian system as it turns out it's
not not as good maybe you know maybe not
as productive but you can do things some
things maybe you can do faster
so you know that's that's a scary thing
then you suddenly realize
you've got to hang on to the idea of the
West to the idea of what we have because
actually maybe it's quite special maybe
it's not so easy to to turn someone else
to that
so
grounds for optimism but but you know
you need you need to be wary as well you
can't just have as a blind optimism that
it'll everything will naturally go in a
western Direction I think the the most
important Point
um is here in all of this conversations
the importance of understanding our
history correctly and this is one of the
reasons I've
been writing and talking about a lot
because if we don't have a healthy view
of ourselves I just don't I think it's
very difficult to then have a confidence
in the future and have the right
attitude about the future uh to deal
with the challenges to come and because
of that I think your documentary is
really really important and beautifully
made you've got some fantastic uh guests
interviewed there people who we've had
on the show as well as others you know
Andrew clavon is in a Nigel bigger you
mentioned uh you know James Bartholomew
a bunch of very very good guests so uh
thank you for making it it was a real
pleasure to be involved uh I hope people
go and check it out it's on the new
culture Forum YouTube channel available
and six is a six part series called the
West make sure you go and check it out
uh we're going to ask you some questions
from our supporters in a second on
locals before we do we've always got the
same final question as you know which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
I think we should be talking about what
to do about our universities perhaps we
are talking about this but we need to be
talking about it more specifically what
happened with the West you can actually
almost date it 1987 protests at Stanford
hey ho hey ho Western siva's got to go
the western civilization course in the
top Elite universities of America were
some of the most important courses they
had and they got torn out because they
were Politically Incorrect they consider
them to be racist
20 30 years later we see what happens
when you I think lots of people are you
know the mass of people are quite ready
to be proud of Western civilization and
to be pleased to learn more about it
when you take it out of the top
institutions that produces the people
who run all the institutions of society
it's it's a disaster and it's very hard
to know how to get the right ideas back
into those places and I think that is
great intellectual challenge of our time
and you know there are great things
people do around the edges they say well
maybe we'll start a new University or
something
powerful it's powerful but there are
things you can only do from the center
we talked about the Supreme Court
earlier Supreme Court and its ability to
make decisions which you know I would
argue stand up for rule of law and in
very important Western principles happen
because of the Federalist society which
worked inside tough American law schools
to to bring top lawyers to think in a
certain way and ultimately to be in a
position of power in the Supreme Court
in America
more broadly what else can we do that's
like that that takes these ideas back
not just not just to the people who are
more receptive to not just in our skills
to everybody but to the people who are
going to have power in our society it's
a problem we've got is people right at
the top who
prefer fashionable ideas about how awful
we are until we can reach them it's very
hard to change things around well I
would argue that actually we've just
done it and you've done it with your
series and the conversations we're
having and people writing books about
these things actually is what will make
that difference because actually I
really agree with you that I think the
overwhelming majority of people in our
countries not just this country but in
any in many others uh uh are ready to
hear a balanced and sensible healthy
message about our past our present and
our future so thank you very much for
coming on and join us on locals where we
will talk more with Mark and ask him
your questions
is there a particular trigger that might
inspire a kind of Renaissance of
confidence here in the West
[Music]